what do you think could happen with cody
garbrandt that that [ __ ] broke my heart
man oh dude dude me too man because i
really like that guy and uh
i mean if i was him i would retire i'm
not i'm not kidding yeah i'm not kidding
man i mean if i was him he's obviously
probably not going to he's
i don't think he gives a [ __ ] i think
he's going to go beat somebody else's
ass now but let me tell you what he's
done it all and here's what makes me the
most
[ __ ] mad about that cody garbrandt
situation and and like i said in the end
it will
god knows he's a fighter that's all that
matters is it like his spirit is strong
and he's a fighter to the death he'll
fight anybody he was cheated out of his
[ __ ] championship belt they did they
went back and uh done blood tests on on
dylan shaw when they fight he fought him
on peds that's what i'm saying [ __ ] that
[ __ ] man so they should have
given it to him
[ __ ] yeah dude i mean it ain't ever
going to happen you know in my book he
is the [ __ ] champ he beat tj
dillashaw off of [ __ ] morals yeah by
not being a little [ __ ] and cheating
before the fight you know what i'm
saying he's already the champion and you
got tj uh
over here in in
garbrandt over there and
[ __ ] [ __ ] street fights breaking
out i'm going on guard branch side every
[ __ ] time that's a real [ __ ] man
i'll die with that [ __ ] man before i
take the little bitch's side yeah you
know what i'm saying i ain't about that
yeah
i ain't about it man yeah and there's
not a lot of they don't go back in time
and kind of correct what no they'll
never go back in time you know what i'm
saying he won't get his reward till he
gets to heaven you know what i'm saying
and god will say hey man i know you are
the champion you are daddy you are and
strap you up baby and i'm telling you
right now that will hang over dilla
shaw's head the rest of his [ __ ] life
yeah he knocked him out twice he ended
his career of what it was right of what
it was now i'm not saying he's done he's
still gonna make ten times more money
than me in my next fight right
garbrandt makes that good money he ain't
done but what i'm saying is he was at
the pinnacle yeah and got removed by a
little cheap shot and [ __ ] right you
know what i'm saying a dude that he
would knock out and practice so this
dude gets knocked out in practice and
says well i'll just go put a needle in
my ass you know what i'm saying and that
burns you up huh it burns me up bro [ __ ]
that [ __ ] yeah you know that's
that's and i'm not gonna hold back and
and uh
i'd say it to his face if he was right
here yeah you know
yeah what do you think leads someone to
to do something like that he's scared
because he got knocked out in practice
and he said you know what uh and and he
justifies it by saying uh
in his head he's gonna say well you know
i need this win it's for me and my
family and all that but man it's like
it's
you're fighting you're signing a
contract like here's what i'm saying if
you're going to be a gangster and going
to be doing [ __ ] by the rules go be a
real gangster tj dillashaw go [ __ ] uh
if you're going to not play by the rules
go with those uh go gangbang yeah you
know what i'm saying yes see how long
your little [ __ ] ass lasts out there
you know what i'm saying go out there
you want to do no rules your ass will
get cheap shotted you know what i'm
saying we're this is a it should be a
fairest possible sport and everybody
should have equal opportunity playing
field and he took away one man's
championship aspirations he took it from
his family and uh do you think he should
have been allowed back in
um
yeah i think that if if you could let
him back in like i think he was clean
his last fight right it didn't look as
good as last fight did you notice that
yeah well i thought because i what that
was a san hagen fight that's right i
thought san hagen could have i thought
that i thought that san hagan won that
fight but yeah i mean it was definitely
not exactly the same i thought san
hangum won two yeah you know he did he
definitely did more damage but if you go
by the scoring system it was a close
fight but damage wise you know who
[ __ ] did more damage yeah tj knows
who did more damage yeah
probably hurt to chew food a couple
weeks you know what i'm saying he knows
he lost that [ __ ] fight yeah yeah
yeah i was backstage and that's when the
cody fight was going on right and we
were watching it
and he said that when you drop down a
weight class like there's less likes
your body's so tight that when you get
knocked out at a lower weight
it's real hard on your system because
you just
you know there's less like fat inside
there's less like cushioning inside of
your legs how do your universe you know
particularly from your brain yeah
because think about this your body knows
how important your brain is when you get
to that final moment in a weight cut
when you're like okay i can't cut no
more that's when your body become begins
to pull the moisture from the brain it's
the last thing that your body will will
protect
that that your body will will keep all
that fluid in your brain until it don't
have fluid from nowhere else and then
your head your brain fluid now guess
which guess which fluid takes some of
the longest to get back into your system
brain that brain fluid
now here's how i knew
that
that cody was really feeling i didn't
think he was going to lose i didn't know
that that's not what i'm saying but
here's how i knew he was feeling he
ain't a [ __ ] 25 right he ain't a 25er
i promise bro he might do good at 25.
he's really a 35 or though because he he
just he's healthier 35 but here's how i
knew
because uh i saw him do a video
garbrandt and he was talking
and i could tell his voice was not um
the same it was when you begin cutting
that much weight i have sinus issues or
you get just extremely dehydrated in a
when you get to that point of extreme
dehydration you'll notice a lot of fluid
change up here
i actually cannot hear i'm not kidding
you wow like there's you ever get water
stuck in here at the pool yeah bro i've
been cutting weight before and it's like
waters in both my ears
and i heard him do this interview
and okay so this is my normal voice i'm
kind of talking i kind of heard him like
kind of like a like his is it was a
different pitch and i could tell
something was up in the up in here just
so dried out bro i was like oh he's dry
and i could see in his cheeks i knew it
brother i knew that is a tough weight
cut and uh and i think that his
performance was probably hindered by the
weight cut and i think that he's a 35er
and uh heartbreaking but but i'm just
telling you by the way he was talking i
could feel it i could feel it in my nose
and my ears he was having sinus issues
bro because when you start you your
fluids drain and then your your brain
fluids drain and then you got this
pressure you can't hear right you can't
smell and how can you fight like that
you can't not the same you know what i'm
saying he didn't
i didn't actually see the whole fight i
just saw highlights of it but brother
he's fast yeah and he didn't look as
fast out there yeah
yeah i can't i can't even imagine the
levels that your body has to go to to do
all of that
i think that that that was just a big
weight cut on him that's what i think
you saw that performance out of him for
and like i said i didn't even see the
fight i just saw highlights of it and
like you said man i just feel bad for
the guy because that's one of those guys
that i just really [ __ ] like man yeah
he's fun to cheer for man yeah and he's
just yeah his his personality he's
[ __ ] vibrant and he's vicious he's
red he's he's always ready
you know uh i think he's like i wish how
i could be just like [ __ ] you know
les you know
yeah
he's got that i think a lot of people
see that in him he does special guy to
watch
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one
you